The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Hi,
I'm John Essigman.
I'm one of the
instructors in 5.07.
I teach with JoAnne
Stubbe and Bogdan Fedeles,
you've probably seen in
earlier videos of this type.
Today we're going to talk about
the pentose phosphate pathway.
Professionally,
I'm a toxicologist.
The pentose phosphate
pathway is one
that is very central to the
people who work in my field,
specifically because the pentose
phosphate pathway provides us
with one of the reagents
that we need in order
to be able to combat
or counter the effects
of oxidative stress.
Oxidative stress is involved
in many pathologies.
One of the reasons that the
pentose phosphate pathway is
challenging to teach
is because it's
a pathway that interacts
very, very closely
with other pathways--
for example, glycolysis,
the energy-generating
pathway in gluconeogenesis,
a pathway by which,
in some organs,
you're able to
synthesize glucose
from non-carbohydrate
precursors.
The fact that these tend
to be so closely related
makes it difficult to
see the distinct features
of the pentose
phosphate pathway.
So let me show you the
pentose phosphate pathway
and how it interacts with
these other pathways.
First of all, let me
start with the roles
of the pentose
phosphate pathway.
As I see it, there are three.
The first is this is
the cell's principle
source of an NADPH, which
is our reductive cofactor.
It's used for the
synthesis of such things
as lipids and other
carbohydrates, and so on.
So this is how the
reducing equivalent,
the source of electrons
that we use in order
to be able to synthesize
complex molecules.
The second major role
of the pentose phosphate
pathway is that it's our
biosynthetic source of ribose.
We have to make ribose
for things like ATP.
We have to make it for
the nucleotides that
are in our nucleic acids.
This is where it comes from.
What we're also going to see
is that when we eat foods
that contain ribose--
for example, ATP
and nucleotides--
this is how they enter the
mainstream of metabolism
so that we can utilize them
as raw material or energy
material.
And the third thing
about the pathway
is that some of the
intermediates you'll
see in what we call this
carbon scrambling phase
are critical for the synthesis
of certain biomolecules.
This is where the
aromatic residues
come from in our aromatic
amino acids, such as tyrosine.
So the pentose phosphate
pathway is very important
because it provides us with
our reducing equivalents.
It provides us with
a biosynthetic source
of ribose for nucleotides.
And it provides us
with building blocks
for more complicated molecules.
Because this pathway is
associated with biosynthesis,
in terms of its providing
reducing equivalents, what
we'll find is that the
pathway is very highly
expressed in tissues
that make a lot of lipid.
Lipid is our bioenergetically
most expensive
biosynthetic process.
Requires a lot of NADPH.
If the cell is dividing,
what it's going to do
is make membranes.
And that's a lot of
lipid biosynthesis.
This pathway, the pentose
phosphate pathway,
not surprisingly,
is upregulated when
we have to make a
lot of membranes--
for example, in a
cell that's growing.
And that means, for
example, that this could be
a target for anti-cancer drugs.
In other words, if you
wanted to find a pathway
to block in order to stop the
provision of the resources,
the reductive
resources for growth,
this would be one that
would be looked at--
in fact, is being looked at
by the modern pharmaceutical
industry.
Over here toward the
center of the top
panel is what's often considered
to be a little bit confusing,
but it's really actually
quite straightforward,
which is the fact that this
pathway can run in two modes.
I said earlier that the
pentose phosphate pathway
is an offshoot of
other pathways, which
makes it a little bit difficult
for some people to understand.
So in this line
right across here
that I'm just moving
across, that's
going from glucose to pyruvate
as we go left to right.
And that's, of
course, glycolysis.
If we went from
pyruvate to glucose--
that is, going from
right to left--
that's gluconeogenesis.
So gluconeogenesis,
for example, might
be a situation in a diabetic.
For example, I'm a diabetic,
and when I go to sleep at night,
I'm not eating, and what my
liver is doing is it's saying,
OK, you haven't
eaten for a while.
Your blood sugar is dropping.
And my gluconeogenesis
pathways start
to manufacturing-- in my
case, unfortunately, too much.
From non-carbohydrate
precursors,
they move the carbon
from right to left
and put out a lot of
glucose into my blood.
That's one of the uses of
the gluconeogenic pathway.
Similarly, if a
Doberman Pinscher,
which has become commonly seen
in the 5.07 course so far,
starts to chase me
down the street, what
I'm going to want
to do is I'm going
to want to take and break
down my glucose as quickly
as possible to bring
it toward pyruvate
to get fast ATP that I can
use to power my muscles
to be able to run away.
So that's the gluconeogenesis
and the glycolysis pathways.
Now imagine that you've
got a railroad track
and that you've got a
side track off of it.
And that's what the pentose
phosphate pathway is.
It is a track that comes off of
glycolysis or gluconeogenesis,
stuff happens, and then you
can re-enter the mainstream
of the train line.
The interesting thing is
that you can basically
go in either direction at
certain parts of this pathway.
What this really means is
we have common components
in both the pentose
phosphate pathway
and along this main line of
gluconeogenesis/glycolysis.
And the common components
we're going to see
are, first, glucose 6-phosphate;
second, fructose 6-phosphate;
and third, glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate, or GAP.
So these are the common
features of all three pathways.
OK, so I'm going to give you a
little bit of an overview first
and show you how this
side track works.
Now, the pathway can be run in
the oxidative mode exclusively.
And what we'll see
is-- and again,
the details will come
in a few minutes--
that this glucose 6-phosphate
is going to be oxidized in order
to generate--
and oxidation, of
course, is when electrons
are removed from the substrate.
And they're going to
be put into an NADP
to form NADPH, which is
our reductive cofactor.
So this is an oxidative arm.
Now, one of the consequences
of this oxidation
is going to be-- we're
going to be losing
a carbon from the six-carbon
glucose 6-phosphate
and we're going to be forming
a pentose, specifically
ribulose 5-phosphate.
It's going to be
easily interconverted
with other pentoses,
five-carbon sugars.
And then I want you to
notice that from here on,
everything is reversible
in the pathway.
Loss of CO2 typically
is irreversible,
so this first arm, the first
oxidative arm, is irreversible.
So if we go from glucose
6-phosphate to pentoses,
that's a one-way street.
The pentoses, if we are in the
process, say, of cell division,
these can be used
to make nucleotides.
And this is how we make
pentoses for nucleic acids.
If we don't need the
pentoses, then the carbon
from the pentoses will
continue along the pathway
and will go into this
complicated carbon-scrambling
network, which we see underlined
with a squiggly line over here
in the center.
And the scrambling will
result in the pentoses being
restructured into fructose
6-phosphate, glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate, so
the carbon can then
continue along the pathway.
So I can imagine the
pathway going like this.
A cell-- let's say it's in a
situation where it is growing
and it needs NADPH,
and it needs pentoses
for making nucleotides.
So it takes and it gets up to
the glucose 6-phosphate step.
And so rather than
progressing in glycolysis,
it takes, as you'll
see, a right-hand turn.
Make the NADPH
that's going to be
needed for making those
membranes of the new cell.
Getting pentoses,
which are going
to convert into nucleotides.
And if you don't use
all of the pentoses,
then what you want to do is you
don't want any waste material,
so you go through the
carbon-scrambling network,
and the remainder
of the material
will go back as fructose
6-phosphate and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
So that's what we'll call the
full pentose phosphate pathway,
with the oxidative and
the non-oxidative portions
distinctly shown.
Everything's oxidative up
to the pentoses generation,
and then it's
non-oxidative from pentoses
through the fructose 6-phosphate
and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
Now in the Case B
over here-- we call it
the purely non-oxidative mode.
Let's say you're in a situation
where you're not growing,
but you do need,
for example, ATP,
and you need pentoses for that.
That's where the
back door comes in.
We're going to be taking,
in this case out of probably
gluconeogenesis--
remember, gluconeogenesis
is the flow of carbon from
right to left in this pathway.
So it could be amino
acids and things
from the tricarboxylic
acid, or TCA cycle,
are flowing carbon
in this direction.
And it goes up into the
gluconeogenic pathway,
and then the
molecule repositories
fill up for a glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and fructose
6-phosphate.
If I were to block
gluconeogenesis right here,
then carbon would flow
in this direction,
would go through the
backdoor of the pathway.
The carbon-scrambling phase
would result ultimately
in pentoses.
So this would be a
biosynthetic route to pentoses.
Again, that's a situation in
which we do not need NADPH.
Perhaps we just need pentoses.
OK, so now let me
get into the details.
In the center of this piece
of paper, what you'll see
is the stoichiometry
of the pathway.
In most of 5.07 so
far, we have seen
that we work with a
single molecule of glucose
working its way to two molecules
of pyruvate, and so on.
Here the tricarboxylic
geometry works out best,
or it's easiest to
teach and to appreciate,
if you start with three
molecules of glucose.
And we'll see why
in a few minutes.
So what we'll do is--
I'm going to do is take
three molecules of glucose
6-phosphate.
Now looking up at
the top here-- so
this is glucose to
glucose 6-phosphate.
This is the entry portion right
here, with glucose 6-phosphate,
into the oxidative
arm of the pathway.
So that's 18 carbons.
3 times 6 is 18.
We're going to lose three CO2s.
That's going to leave
us 15 carbons left.
And those 15 carbons are
going to be distributed
among two fructose 6-phosphates
and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
So here's the
fructose 6-phosphate.
Here's the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
That's the overall
stoichiometry of the pathway.
So now what I'm
going to do is go
through the chemical
details of the pathway,
down here at the bottom
and on the next page.
We've got glucose going
to glucose 6-phosphate.
And I draw three lines
there because I'll
say this glucose 6-phosphate
is the abbreviation that I
use for the structure
that's shown right here.
So this is glucose
6-phosphate with
the proper stereochemistry.
Now the hydroxyl
group on the glucose--
we don't really know what
its stereochemistry is,
but we've got it up or
in beta in this drawing.
The first step is for
the enzyme glucose
6-phosphate
dehydrogenase, G6PDH,
to attack the one carbon.
The electrons go down to
make a keto functionality.
We lose hydride from the one
carbon, which is used then
to reduce NADP to NADPH.
So that's our first
oxidation step.
I want you to notice that
this is a one-way arrow.
Typically at the top of a
pathway-- and in this case,
it's at the very top--
these are the steps that are
thermodynamically irreversible.
These are also the steps
where you principally effect
regulation of the pathway.
And as I said
earlier, we're going
to be running three molecules
of glucose 6-phosphate
through this step.
The next molecule in
the pathway is this one.
This is a lactone.
A lactone is a cyclic ester.
So this is an ester, and
you can see it's cyclic.
The next step involves
the addition of water
by lactonase in order to open
up this six-membered ring
to give you this linear
structure that we'll see here.
And this is basically
6-phosphoglucuronic acid.
The next step will
involve the oxidation
of the 1, 2, 3 carbon.
I always try to find
places in any pathway
where we've seen the
same chemistry before
but with different molecules.
This step right
here, specifically
working with lactonase and
the enzyme 6 phosphogluconate
dehydrogenase--
I'd like you to look back at
the tricarboxylic acid cycle,
specifically at the enzyme
isocitrate dehydrogenase.
While some of the specifics
are different, basically what
you'll see is the
overall concept
is the same for what's happening
in the next couple of steps.
So let me now get
back to the drawing.
So what we have
here is the 1, 2,
3 carbon is vulnerable to what's
going to be an oxidation event.
So a base will
remove the hydrogen
from the 3-hydroxyl group.
The electrons that were holding
the hydrogen to the oxygen
will now move down to the
position between the oxygen
and the 3 carbon.
And then the hydride
on the 3 carbon
will be transferred
to NADP to make NADPH.
So this is the second
of two oxidation steps.
That gives us this ring
open structure here.
And just as happens in the
isocitrate dehydrogenase
step, what we've done is we've
generated a beta ketoacid.
Whenever you see
a beta ketoacid,
you really always want
to think that that's
prone to either enzymatic or
spontaneous decarboxylation.
What you can see is the
electrons can go like this
and like this and
like this, and that
will result in the cleavage
of the bond connecting
carbon 1 and carbon 2.
So now the new
carbon 1 will be the
what was carbon 2, which
is the carbon that has
this little purple ball on it.
And we're going to lose the
terminal, or 1 carbon, as CO2.
The CO2 will have the triangle,
which up until this point
has defined our 1 carbon.
Now I just want to mention
a couple of things.
One is that we'll look at--
I put on-- like
here's a dark ball.
Here's a purple ball, and
here's a black triangle.
These could be-- for
example, experimentally,
you could use a radioactive
chemical, a radioactive atom,
in order to help you
trace the reaction as you
go from precursor to product.
I'm using these just to help
you see the relationship
of a precursor and a product.
And what we see here
is that the 1 carbon
is lost from the
beta ketoacid as CO2
and according to the kind
of chemistry that we've seen
many times for decarboxylation.
Now, this is going to give
us a five-carbon product.
We've lost the CO2.
And that is ribulose
5-phosphate.
And for this, I'm going
to go on to the next page.
On the previous page,
we saw the loss of CO2
from the 1 carbon of
the beta ketoacid.
And this gives us this linear
structure, five-carbon ribulose
5-phosphate.
I've drawn it this
way so you can see it
from the perspective of what
was a six-carbon molecule that's
lost one carbon.
But the more formal
chemical way to draw this
would be as the linear
chain of five carbons
starting with the new 1
carbon, which is the alcohol,
with a purple circle.
The next carbon would
have the carbonyl group,
which I'll use a blue box.
And all the way
down to what is now
the five-carbon-- what was
originally the six-carbon--
which has the dark black dot.
Now because we're processing
three molecules of hexose
and now pentose, where
we've got three molecules
of ribulose 5-phosphate,
and the two enzymes that
are going to process this are
ribulose 5-phosphate isomerase
and ribulose
5-phosphate epimerase.
Now, just because of
the relative activities
of these enzymes, we're going
to see that about one-third
of the molecules will be
processed by the isomerase
and two-thirds will be
processed by the epimerase.
Now, let me tell you a little
bit about what isomerization
is, versus epimerization.
Bogdan and others have told
you about the importance
of enediol or diolate
intermediates in biochemistry.
The section of the molecule
in the ribulose 5-phosphate
that I'm circling here,
if you just take and form
an enediolate here,
what you can do
is you can move the carbonyl
functionality from the 2 carbon
up to the 1 carbon.
And that's what happens when
you convert ribulose 5-phosphate
into ribose 5-phosphate.
So it's a simple
enediol conversion.
Very similarly, I could
have made the enediol
between the 2 and the 3 carbon.
And if I did that,
I'll form an enediol.
And depending on how
I put the hydrogen
back on that I take off, I
can change the stereochemistry
at the 3 carbon.
In other words, I can form
the epimer at the 3 carbon.
So I can go from this
epimer on the top
to where the hydroxyl group
is pointed to the right,
to this epimer on the bottom,
where the hydroxyl group is
pointed to the left.
This molecule, the epimer of
ribulose 5-phosphate, where
the hydroxyl on 3 is
pointed to the left,
is called xylulose 5-phosphate.
As I said, this enzyme,
this epimerase enzyme,
is a little more active
than the isomerase enzyme.
So we get about two molecules
of the xylulose 5-phosphate
for every molecule
that we process--
again, by enediolate-type
intermediates
to form the ribose 5-phosphate.
So this gives us a--
ribulose 5-phosphate
is now converted
into one molecule of
ribose 5-phosphate and two
molecules of
xylulose 5-phosphate.
I'm going to give you a little
bit of a mechanistic interlude
here to remind you that
some of the chemistry I'm
going to be showing you with
the enzyme transketolase
is very reminiscent
of chemistry we
have seen several times
in 5.07, specifically
the enzymes pyruvate
dehydrogenase,
pyruvate decarboxylase,
and alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase.
Now, the molecule
that I have right here
in this little
mechanistic interlude box
is one of the ones we
were just talking about.
Specifically, this is
xylulose 5-phosphate.
You see the epimer with the
3-hydroxyl off on the left.
This carbonyl group is
exactly the type of carbonyl
that's attackable by
thiamine pyrophosphate, TPP.
Let me remind you a
little bit about why
TPP can be a nucleophile to
attack this carbonyl group.
TPP, when you look at
the whole cofactor,
it has attached up
here an aminopyridine.
And the amino group can
be in the imino tautomer,
and that imino tautomer can
help pull off this hydrogen,
lowering the PK.
So the PK of this is
actually something
in the order of
18 or 19, which is
sufficient to make this
carbon a good nucleophile
to be able to attack
the carbonyl that's
on our, in this case,
xylulose 5-phosphate.
That attack will result in the
formation of an initial adduct
in which the vitamin, the
TPP, is covalently associated
with the xylulose 5-phosphate.
You can see that the keto
group has been converted
into a hydroxyl group.
So we've now got a dihydroxy
molecule at this point.
And just as we've seen with
the other enzymes I mentioned
earlier-- for example, the
pyruvate dehydrogenase--
the delocalization of
electrons through this system
makes it possible
to be able to remove
this hydrogen. These electrons
move to this position.
These electrons move up here.
And that means that the bond
connecting the bottom three
carbons of the xylulose
5-phosphate is broken,
and that gives you--
if you look at the chemistry--
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
the very common biochemical
intermediate.
And what's left over
is the vitamin TPP
attached to two-carbon unit.
And it's called
dihydroxyethyl TPP.
Hydroxy, hydroxy, this
is an ethyl group,
and it's an anion,
the TPP anion.
So I abbreviate that minus,
and then with a box, C2-TPP.
It's a chemically reactive
nucleophilic intermediate
that we're going to be able to
use to do powerful chemistry.
The enzyme
transketolase, which I'm
going to talk about
from the standpoint
of medical importance
somewhat later,
enables the removal of
the top two carbons,
via the chemistry
I just showed you.
It's a kind of a
chemical decapitation
to remove the C2-TPP in order
to liberate it to be able to be
used as a chemical reagent.
So both of our molecules of
xylulose 5-phosphate are going
to be susceptible
to this chemistry,
and that means we're going
to get two molecules of this
C2-TPP anion--
one here and one here--
and two molecules
of glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate-- here and here.
OK?
What are we going to
do with the C2-TPP?
Well, I want to draw your
attention back up here
to the ribulose 5-phosphate.
Remember, I told you
that it's possible,
by way of an enediolate
intermediate,
with this isomerase
enzyme, to move
the carbonyl group from the
2 carbon up to the 1 carbon.
And that produces
ribose 5-phosphate.
One of the things that I
just want to point out here
is ribose 5-phosphate was
one of the things that's one
of the goals of the pathway.
So I could, for example, stop
the pathway here and shunt off
this ribose 5-phosphate to
be able to make nucleotides.
But this carbonyl is exactly
the kind of functional group
that the C2-TPP looks for,
for chemical reaction.
So I can plug in,
just like a LEGO,
the C2-TPP on the five-carbon
ribose 5-phosphate.
What that does is gives me--
5 plus 2 is 7--
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
And just because of the
way the chemistry works,
we've basically pushed out the
hydroxyl group at this position
off on the left, on
the number 3 carbon.
OK, so now we have a
seven-carbon molecule.
And again, this is another
biosynthetic opportunity.
As I said earlier,
ribose 5-phosphate
can go off to make
ribonucleotides.
If you look up the
pathway of synthesis
of the aromatic amino acid
tyrosine, what you'll see
is that basically this is the
biosynthetic intermediate that
will go off to produce
that aromatic amino acid.
OK, so this is
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
Now if I look at the
top three carbons here,
you've got basically an alcohol,
a carbonyl, and an alcohol.
This looks almost identical
to the carbon 1, 2, and 3
that you see in the aldolase
reaction back in glycolysis.
In other words, the
linear form of--
in that case, it's
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate--
in the linear form looks
very much like this.
And what that means is
that the aldolase enzyme,
with its amino group
at its active site,
can attack this
carbonyl group to form
a protonated imine that will--
in the process of
the chemistry, you
can break the bond
that connects carbon
3 to carbon 4 of this molecule.
So the enzyme transaldolase
that does this chemistry
is very similar to
the aldolase enzyme
that we have looked at in
the glycolysis pathway.
This is the splitting,
in this case,
of a seven-carbon compound
into a three-carbon
and a four-carbon, whereas
in the case of glycolysis,
it was splitting a
six-carbon compound into two
three-carbon compounds.
This intermediate that I'm
encircling here with the imine
is very similar to the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
precursor.
So I'll call it a
DHA-like fragment--
two methanol groups with a
methyl imine in the middle.
So what we've done is
I've taken the top three
carbons of the
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate
and made it into something
that looks a lot like carbons
1, 2, and 3 from the aldolase
step of the glycolysis pathway.
So it's a dihydroxyacetone-like
phosphate.
I'm just going to put that
off to the side for a minute.
The bottom four carbons,
carbons 4, 5, 6, and 7
of the sedoheptulose
7-phosphate,
are something we haven't
actually seen in 5.07 before.
But if we look at
what the structure is,
it's going to be an aldehyde--
one, two, three,
four-carbon aldehyde.
And this is erythrose
4-phosphate, E4P.
Now, that in itself is
not a valuable molecule.
But it turns out
that we can make it
into a valuable
molecule very easily.
Remember back when
we were talking
about this C2-TPP
electrophilic molecule that
can put two carbons
onto anything that
has an aldehyde at the end?
Well, erythrose 4-phosphate
has an aldehyde at the end.
If we do the chemistry and
we plug this C2 fragment
onto the erythrose 4-phosphate
fragment up at the aldehyde,
you get a six-carbon compound
that is fructose 6-phosphate.
So this is the source
of fructose 6-phosphate
that can then become part of the
gluconeogenesis or glycolysis
pathways.
So we haven't wasted anything.
We've taken a kind
of a trash molecule,
the erythrose
4-phosphate, that we
don't have a lot
of other uses for,
and we've converted
into something
that we can use for energy
production, just as an example.
Now what I'd like to
do is come back up
to this dihydroxyacetone-like
fragment
that I talked about
a little bit ago.
In the glycolysis pathway, we
start with the hexose glucose,
and eventually, after
about four or five steps,
we get to another hexose,
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
Then the aldolase step takes
and splits that in half
into, on the one hand, a
dihydroxyacetone-like fragment
and, on the other hand, a
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
fragment.
And the dihydroxyacetone-like
fragment
is covalently connected by
way of its middle carbon,
the carbonyl, to
the enzyme aldolase.
When we look at what's happening
in the transaldolase reaction,
it's really the same thing.
We've taken the seven-carbon
molecule, in this case,
and we've split off this
three-carbon intermediate.
Again, it's chemically just
about identical to what
happened in glycolysis,
when we pulled apart
the six-carbon
sugar and we've now
got this thing on the right
which we can do something with.
The dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is covalently connected
to the enzyme transaldolase.
It's a transaldolase.
It can do the aldolase
reaction, the splitting,
but then it can take and it
can transfer very easily.
What are we going
to transfer it to?
Well the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate chemically
can be transferred very easily
to glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
So I'm going to find
a way now to connect
this dihydroxyacetone-like
fragment
to a glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And I find one right here.
Let me go back a little bit
and see where it came from.
I had the xylulose 5-phosphate.
I knocked off the
top two carbons.
I used those in order to make
the sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
My residue was the
three-carbon molecule
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
But again, this could be a
waste product, but instead
of using it as a waste
product, what I can do
is to take the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate that
is a waste product of the
transketolase reaction
down here, and I can
utilize it by combination
with the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate from up here,
the transaldolase reaction.
Transaldolase has
the transfer ability
to bring these molecules
together covalently, plug them
together, 3 and 3, to make 6.
And that's your second molecule
of fructose 6-phosphate.
While I've still got this sheet
with the whole pathway on it,
I'm going to give you a
little bit of a summary.
I took three molecules
of glucose 6-phosphate,
oxidized it twice, generated
two molecules for each molecule
of glucose 6-phosphate.
I got two molecules of NADPH,
the reducing equivalents.
The pathway up to that point
created a beta ketoacid.
Therefore there was this
decarboxylation event.
So what I ended up with is
three five-carbon molecules,
ribulose 5-phosphate.
The ribulose
5-phosphate, depending
upon the balance of activities
of the next two enzymes,
will partition at
about a 2-to-1 ratio
into xylulose 5-phosphate
and ribose 5-phosphate.
Then I explained how the
xylulose 5-phosphate had
this carbonyl at
the second position,
and that looked
like the carbonyl
in a lot of other
biochemical reactions
we've seen earlier in 5.07.
And it's vulnerable to attack
by the ylid carbanion of TPP,
thiamine pyrophosphate.
Applying that
transketolase enzyme
to xylulose 5-phosphate
split off the top two carbons
as this electrophilic chemical
reagent that I call C2-TPP.
The bottom three carbons became
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
The C2-TPP got added onto
ribose 5-phosphate, which
is one of the molecules that was
made from the early-on ribulose
5-phosphate.
That made the
seven-carbon molecule
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate.
And again, I said that that's
a precursor to other things,
like aromatic amino
acids, if you need them.
The sedoheptulose
7-phosphate, however,
has a structure that makes
it amenable to having
its top three carbons taken
off by an aldolase-like enzyme,
transaldolase.
What makes this
aldolase special is it
will take the three carbons
off as a protein three-carbon
adduct and allow
that three carbons
to be added onto one of the
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates
that was generated in the
transketolase reaction.
3 plus 3 is 6, and that becomes
your fructose 6-phosphate.
Overall, what happens is you put
in three glucose 6-phosphates,
you lose some CO2s,
and you produce
two fructose
6-phosphates and one
leftover glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
And these are in the
mainstream of glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis.
So that's the details
of the pathway.
We start with a
six-carbon compound,
three molecules of
it, and we generate
three molecules of CO2.
We're going to generate
six molecules of NADPH.
And at the beginning of the
page that we're looking at here,
we have three molecules
of a five-carbon compound,
this ribulose 5-phosphate.
And again, at this point,
the carbon-scrambling phase
takes over.
And at the end, we
end up with taking
the 15 carbons of the three 5
carbon ribulose 5-phosphates,
and scrambling them into
two six-carbon fructose
6-phosphates and one
three-carbon glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
We've now looked at
the pentose phosphate
pathway from two levels.
Let's say initially, what I see
right here is the pathway from,
let's say, the
10,000-foot level.
We see there's the mainstream
of metabolism of glucose
to pyruvate--
that's glycolysis-- or pyruvate
to glucose, gluconeogenesis.
And we have seen how in the
pentose phosphate pathway,
we go from glucose
6-phosphate, we
do some oxidation-- that's
why you get the NADPH.
You lose some CO2.
You get the pentoses.
I've introduced you to ribose,
ribulose, and xylulose.
Then in order to get
these pentoses back
into mainstream
metabolism, we do
this complicated
carbon-scrambling routine,
and then get back to fructose
6-phosphate and GAP to be
able to continue in
mainstream metabolism.
Nothing is wasted.
There's the 10,000-foot level.
And then I went, down
here at the bottom,
to sort of the 2-foot level,
all the little details
of the chemistry.
So I've taught you this, the
pentose phosphate pathway,
in the beginning at
the 10,000-foot level,
and then got you down to
the 2-foot level with all
of the details of the
chemical mechanisms.
And our course,
Biological Chemistry 5.07,
is a chemistry course, so
that's very appropriate.
But 5.07 is also 25.07.
20 is the Biological
Engineering department.
And the engineers actually
think a lot about, let's say,
mathematical equations more
than chemical equations.
And they think about
schematics, written out
like you'd look at an
electrical schematic.
So because the Biological
Chemistry group
we have is quite large,
we have kind of an ending
to this pathway that appeals, I
think, to more the engineering
mindset.
So for the engineers, I'm going
to move from the two-foot level
up to about the 100-foot level.
And I'm going to present
it as a schematic.
The shorthand that I use
involves these little boxes.
Each of these is a molecule.
And the abbreviation
is in the top--
G6P, glucose 6-phosphate.
It has six carbons.
That'll help me keep track of
how many carbons are there.
And there are three
molecules of it.
So we've got 6 times 3, or 18
carbons, that we start with.
In the oxidative phase,
we've seen that each molecule
gives rise to two NADPHs.
2 times 3 is 6.
So we've got 6 NADPHs.
There are three molecules that
are starting, and remember
that beta ketoacid
that's formed?
We have three of those, and
they're going to carboxylate.
So I get rid of three CO2s.
So the broken line
indicates the boundary
between the irreversible
and the reversible parts
of the reaction.
This gives us
ribulose 5-phosphate.
That's our initial product
entering the pathway.
It's a five-carbon molecule.
There are three molecules
of it, total of 15 carbons.
Depending upon the activities
of the epimerase in the bottom--
E-- or the isomerase--
I-- on the top, you either
get more or less of the X5P,
xylulose 5-phosphate, or
ribose 5-phosphate, R5P.
And as I said,
typically the epimerase
wins out by about 2-to-1
over the isomerase.
So we've got a
simple isomerization
to take the ribulose 5-phosphate
to ribose 5-phosphate.
It's a C5 molecule.
You get one of those.
So we've got five of
our carbons over here.
If we look at the
epimerase reactions,
we get two boxes,
one for each molecule
of xylulose 5-phosphate.
Each of them are C51.
So those are our two molecules.
Now let's take our first
molecule of xylulose
5-phosphate, the one
in the top X5P box.
And again, keep in mind
that these arrowheads
are going both ways.
Because the carbon can flow
both ways in these reactions.
These are equilibrium reactions.
We can take the top two
carbons off of the X5P.
This is the thiamine
pyrophosphate reaction.
And what that does is it gives
us that chemically reactive
C2-TPP fragment.
Carbon 2, two
carbons, one of those.
OK?
And the bottom half is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate--
a three-carbon
molecule, one of those.
The ribose 5-phosphate,
the five-carbon aldehyde,
can have the C2-TPP
add to it's one carbon.
2 carbons plus 5 carbons give 7.
Sedoheptulose 7-phosphate
is the product--
one molecule of those.
Transaldolase can split
off the top three carbons
to make that
dihydroacetone-like fragment.
This is the one
that's covalently
attached by this imine-like
bond to the triose sugar.
Three-carbon sugar--
one molecule of that.
And after you do this
transaldolase reaction
and you've taken off
the top three carbons,
you've got a residue
of four carbons.
So that's the erythrose
4-phosphate, C4, one molecule.
Now, the transaldolase
reaction can do a transfer.
So you'll take this DHA,
dihydroxyacetone-like fragment,
and combine it with
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
that it got from the molecule
1 of xylulose 5-phosphate.
So we can follow the schematic.
Xylulose 5-phosphate gives
us this gap molecule,
glyceraldehyde 3phosphate.
It can combine
with the molecule,
the DHA-like fragment, to
form for our first molecule
of fructose 6-phosphate,
which will then
go off into glycolysis
or gluconeogenesis.
Now, the residue of this was
this erythrose 4-phosphate
product.
What can we do with it?
For again, this is an aldehyde.
It can react with a C2
fragment from the C2-TPP.
So where we get that C2-TPP
is from our second molecule
of xylulose 5-phosphate.
Transketolase takes
off the top two carbons
and plunks it onto the
erythrose 4-phosphate to form
our second molecule of two
of fructose 6-phosphate.
C6, one molecule.
And what's left over
after all is said and done
is this fragment right here,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
C3 molecule, one molecule.
So if I did this
correctly, we should
have 15 carbons over here--
6, 6, and 3--
and we do.
So these are the molecules
that will flow into glycolysis
or gluconeogenesis.
Now because most of these
arrows are double-headed,
you can also imagine
that fructose
6-phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
in the mainstream metabolism, in
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis,
can backflow right to left and
end up with these pentoses.
So for example, if I wanted
to make ribose 5-phosphate
in order to make
ATP, and I didn't
need any reducing
equivalents, all I
would do is run all of this in
reverse, get up to this point,
ribose 5-phosphate,
and then take this off
to make nucleotides.
On the other hand,
if I'd like to make
just NADPH for biosynthesis,
what I would do
is the following.
I'd start with my
glucose-6 phosphate.
Early on, yield my 6 NADPHs.
Go from left to right
across the pathway,
all the way to produce
fructose 6-phosphate and GAP.
And then what I'd do is I'd
use gluconeogenesis in order
to convert fructose
6-phosphate and GAP back
into glucose 6-phosphate that
then would be able to re-enter
the pathway once again.
Now, what I want to
do is to show you
that, I want to go back to the
original drawing that I had,
to show you how that would work.
So what I just said was that
if I were in a situation
where all I wanted was NADPH,
I could do the following.
I could enter the carbon
from glucose 6-phosphate,
make the pentoses, get my
NADPH, and then take the carbon
and flush it back through
the scrambling phase
to produce fructose
6-phosphate and GAP.
Now here's the
important part, is
I can now, through
gluconeogenesis,
move the carbon back up
to glucose 6-phosphate
and do it again, and
again, and again.
In other words,
recursively, I can
metabolize all of the carbon
from glucose 6-phosphate.
All six carbons can eventually
become converted into CO2
with copious amounts of NADPH.
And that's part of the
power of this pathway.
It's very versatile.
You can use it to make
reducing equivalents.
You can use it to make sugars.
You can use it to make
sedoheptulose 7-phosphate
to make aromatic amino acids.
It's a very powerful pathway.
The top part of this
picture shows us
the schematic of the pathway.
And I think with the
schematic up there,
I think this is a good time
to make some summary comments.
So one thing I mentioned
at the very beginning
is that we need NADPH in
order to finance biosynthesis
of lipids--
in particular for
making membranes.
So these are needed for growth.
So I think now you can see
why this pathway is turned
on in cells that are
making new tissue, that
are making new cells.
If you run it in
the oxidative mode--
that's the one that
I just described,
where you purely use
it to make NADPH--
you can oxidize all the carbons
of your glucose 6-phosphate
into CO2.
That's the scenario
that I just ran.
I didn't emphasize enough
that if, for example, you
eat food that contains
nucleic acid, which of course
we all do, that nucleic
acid contains ribose.
That ribose, we want to be
able to do something with.
And what happens is it enters
right here into the pathway.
In other words, if I
wanted to take that ribose
and if I wanted to
make energy out of it,
the ribose would go
from left to right,
and I would end up with
fructose 6-phosphate,
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
And then I could use that,
putting it through glycolysis
and then the TCA
cycle to make energy.
Point 4 is one that
I mentioned earlier.
I'm a toxicologist,
and point 4 shows
how NADPH helps us defend
against oxidative stress.
And I have this little
cartoon at the bottom.
Free radicals are a
consequence of living
in an aerobic environment.
We breathe oxygen. It can
be incompletely reduced
to produce things like
superoxide and hydrogen
peroxide and even
hydroxyl radical.
These are chemically
very dangerous,
and they'll form peroxides
and other molecules that
can cause disease.
So we have protective
systems based on a variety
of small molecules in the cell.
One of them is
called glutathione.
Millimolar concentrations
of glutathione
exist in our liver cells,
and they exist in order
to be able to do the
kind of chemistry I'm
going to show you right here.
So a peroxide that
I'm pointing to,
ROOH, is dangerous
because it can give rise
to these free radicals
that can be damaging to us.
What we can do is take
two molecules of this
sulfur-containing glutathione--
it's a tripeptide--
and they will give up their
H dot dot, their hydrides,
in order to be able to basically
break this ROOH into ROH
and alcohol and HOH, water--
in other words, relatively
harmless products.
Now, glutathione, the RSH--
sometimes called GSH--
sacrifices itself and becomes
this oxidized form, RSSR.
Now, the reaction that
does this first part's
called glutathione peroxidase.
In order to restore our cellular
stores of reduced glutathione,
RSH, we have to take
the oxidized form, RSSR,
and we have to reduce it.
That's where the NADPH comes in.
NADPH is the cofactor used
by glutathione reductase.
And what it does is puts
in the reducing equivalents
to basically convert
oxidized glutathione back
to what we want, which is
the reduced glutathione, that
can then go on to protect
us against free radicals.
NADPH has a very special
role in protecting any cell
from oxidative stress.
It has a very special
role, however,
when you deal with
red blood cells.
Red blood cells lack a nucleus.
They lack a mitochondrion.
They're pretty much
entirely cytosol.
Cytosol has a
glycolysis pathway.
That's where they
get their energy.
And the pentose
phosphate pathway,
which is where they get the
reducing equivalents that
are necessary to help
maintain the red blood
cells' integrity-- if
you think about it,
you know, a red blood cell's
carrying a lot oxygen.
Oxygen itself can
be very damaging.
Red blood cells are
damaged, and you really
need to have these reducing
equivalents available in order
to maintain the structural
and functional integrity
of a red blood cell.
So anything that disrupts the
NADPH pool in a red blood cell
ultimately causes
a kind of anemia,
because that means the red
blood cell can't persist
as long as it would otherwise.
People who have defects in
NADPH metabolism-- for example,
a person who might have a defect
or a sluggish first enzyme
in the pathway, the glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase--
the red blood cells, because
of this NADPH problem,
don't last as long.
Clinically, it's observed
that these people
have somewhat of a
resistance against diseases
such as malaria.
That might be
because the red blood
cells don't last long
enough for the organism that
causes malaria,
Plasmodium falciparum,
to be able to complete
its life cycle.
So sometimes a genetic defect
can actually provide an asset.
And in some places in the
world where people have evolved
in the presence of the
malaria Plasmodium organism,
they have defects
in the pathway that
are maintained, from
generation to generation,
in order to be resistant
to the environment.
The sixth point that
I want to bring up
with regard to this
pathway has to do
with the enzyme at the
top of the pathway,
once again, the glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase.
I mentioned it at
the very beginning,
but I want to
reiterate that enzymes
that are at the top of
a pathway where there
is thermodynamically
reversible steps,
they are places where you have
the ability to control entry
into the pathway.
So these are the
rate-determining steps.
And in this case, the
presence of NAD+--
that is, the product--
determines the rate of
passage through the pathway.
So for example, if a
cell has been doing a lot
of biosynthesis, the
NADP+ levels go up.
That interacts
allosterically in order
to be able to increase the
throughput of the pathway.
So you increase
the amount of NADPH
biosynthesis to be
able to let it match
the biosynthetic needs
associated with doing
a lot of lipid biosynthesis.
So this is the regulated step.
The last thing I'm going to
say about the pentose phosphate
pathway is that it's strikingly
similar to the pathway called
the Calvin cycle, which
are the dark reactions
of photosynthesis.
Photosynthesis involves
the capture of one CO2
into a five-carbon scaffold
to make a six-carbon compound.
Then that six-carbon
compounds splits
into three-carbon compounds.
It turns out if you work
with enough molecules
of five-carbon compound,
what you're able to do
is go through the
carbon-scrambling phase
and work all your way back
to the hexose glucose.
The carbon-scrambling
intermediates
are almost identical
chemically to the ones
that we have just looked at in
the pentose phosphate pathway.
So if you look at
the Calvin cycle,
you'll see three-carbon and
four-carbon and five-carbon and
six-carbon and even seven-carbon
intermediates, identical.
So nature, again, didn't
reinvent the wheel twice.
What it did was at
some point in time,
it took the pentose
phosphate pathway
and it converted it into the
photosynthetic dark reactions,
or perhaps vice versa.
They have different purposes.
The photosynthetic pathway
involves capturing carbon
in order to make
hexoses that we can
use to store for energy,
future energy use,
or to make hexoses you
could use to make cellulose,
if you're a plant.
On the other hand,
the pentose phosphate
pathway-- again,
the same chemistry.
But in this case,
the chemistry is all
aimed at taking the hexose,
the six-carbon compound,
and using it to make
reducing equivalents
that we can use
for biosynthesis,
or to protect us from
oxidative stress,
or to make riboses that we need
when we're growing, in order
to be able to make nucleic
acids, nucleotides, ATP,
and so on, that we need.
The pentose phosphate
pathway may seem a little bit
difficult to learn.
But I think it's
very worthwhile.
It is something that provides
us with amazing versatility.
It gives us compounds
that are chemically
reactive at the level of two
carbons, three carbons, four
carbons, five carbons, six
carbons, and seven carbons.
You can take these
pieces and you
can make a wide array of
molecules that are absolutely
essential for life.
Moreover, it provides us
with reducing equivalents,
which we need to grow--
biosynthesis.
Moreover, those reducing
equivalents also
help protect us from
oxidative stress.
That helps keep us alive
and healthy longer.
So the pentose phosphate
pathway is complicated
because it does so
many different things.
But any one of those
things, I think, in itself
makes it worthwhile learning all
of this complicated chemistry.
So that's the pentose phosphate
pathway from the 10,000-foot
level down to the 2-foot level.
Incredibly versatile
pathway, and I
hope that this has
helped you understand it.
Thank you very much.